diese knusprige herzhafte brusketta ist
der beste Weg um in ein Abendessen zu
starten es schmeckt einfach nach Italien
unglaublich eine echte brusketta braucht
nicht viele Zutaten Tomate Basilikum
Knoblauch und natürlich Brot und
natürlich Olivenöl nehmen wir zunächst
einmal unsere Tomate ganz ganz ganz
wichtig ist dass ihr für brusketta gute
Tomaten kauft wenn ihr wässrige Tomaten
kauft können ihr es auch gleich sein
lassen unsere Tomaten sind in Würfel
geschnitten und jetzt geen wir die
wichtigste Zutat dran Salz Tomaten ohne
Salz sind einfach schlechtere Tomaten
Basilikum dazu bisschen Pfeffer noch
etwas Olivenöl und durchrühren jetzt
geen wir unser chabat in ordentlich
Olivenöl und rösten es von beiden Seiten
an dann nehmen wir uns das geröstete
Brot ich habe den Knoblauch nicht
vergessen sondern er kommt jetzt erst
zum Einsatz jetzt gehen wir mit der
Schnittkante über das noch warme raue
geröstete Brot drüber und dann fehlt nur
noch die Mischung bchen abtropfen lassen
damit es nicht so unser Brot aufweicht
und großzügig auf unser chabat geben
wunderbar und eine Sache dar für mich
persönlich nicht fehlen ich mache immer
noch ein bisschen schön gereiften
Balsamico Essig drauf